so President Trump held a campaign rally
in Florida yesterday and he floated the
idea of creating his own propaganda news
network now of course we've all been
watching the trump presidency unfold
over the past three years shouldn't be a
terrible surprise to us that he wants to
do this but I think still anytime you
have a president talking about creating
his own state-run media agency that
should give us a little bit of pause
right so yesterday at the speech Trump
was talking about his normal things how
the media is just the worst they're
corrupt they're the enemy of the people
how CNN is especially bad and then he
gives us this little gem CNN is a voice
that really seems to be the voice out
there and it's a terrible thing for our
country and we ought to start our own
Network and put some real news out there
because they are so bad they are so bad
for our country they are so bad for our
country I go out there and they say boy
in the media hates your country and it's
just a shame it's just a shame and we
really are we are looking at that we
should do something about it to put some
really talented people and get a real
voice out there not a voice that's fake
yeah and Trump also said that he would
get the best people to work in his
administration - and we all know how
that turned out not so well I don't
trust that he would be able to get the
best people to work at his news outlet
either of course there's a serious angle
to all this it's more Trump giving in to
his authoritarian tendencies it's more
Trump attacking the press it's not good
that Trump supporters just view the
president as the ultimate source of
truth and knowledge we don't want to see
that we don't want to see people just
unequivocally buying into whatever the
government tells them but I also want to
talk about how this is just a sort of a
logical progression of Trump's
relationship with the media because of
course for the longest time
Trump's go-to was Fox News Fox News and
Trump were buddy-buddy there were two
peas in a pod that was true for when
Trump was running for president and it
was true for the first two or so years
of trumps administration but then with
signs of an economic downturn on the
horizon and the Muller report stuff
coming out with the Ukraine scandal
there started to be a little bit of a
divide Trump turning on some of the Fox
News hosts Fox at times turning on Trump
so
we have one tweet here I want to show
you where Trump turns on Fox he says I
don't want to win for myself I only want
to win for the people the new Fox News
is letting millions of great people down
we have to start looking for a new news
outlet Fox isn't working for us anymore
going on to say watching fake news CNN
is better than watching Shepard Smith
the lowest rated show on Fox News
actually whenever possible I turn to Oh
a and n so oann is one american news
network it is a right-wing outlet that's
even more favorable to trump than even
Fox News is which is kind of hard to
believe but it's true and yeah I wonder
like why is Trump no longer satisfied
with Oh a a net maybe they're not big
enough maybe they're just not ready for
it or maybe he just doesn't want to go
through the heartbreak again because
Trump and Fox News for the longest time
there were buddy-buddy they were two
peas in a pod and then he has to go
through that tumultuous breakup with
them and I don't know if he wants to go
through that heartbreak again I don't
know I don't know if he wants to trust
in another news organization again I
think he just wants to take the power in
his own hands and me and in control of
the propaganda could this be another
Trump TV preview like remember back in
2016 in the lead-up to the election
pretty much everyone thought that Trump
was going to lose and I think even Trump
himself thought he was going to lose so
there were plans in the works to make a
Trump TV maybe Trump is planning for
life post presidency maybe he expects to
lose in 2020 or maybe he expects to be
impeached and convicted by the Senate
and kicked out of office I won't hold my
breath over that stuff but I think it
does stand to reason that he wants to
get his chips in order so we have some
backup plans in case he does get kicked
out pretty soon and let's remember too
that Trump already has his own
propaganda show it's called the real
news update with lera Trump Trump's
daughter-in-law and it's truly vile
stuff we talked about it a couple years
ago when the show debuted but not since
they're still making that show they are
still making that show I'm gonna show
you a clip Burma now despite attempts
from the fake news to derail the
progress made of the summit the
president was a statesman and bravely
put America first along with the first
lady yeah so truly vile stuff here but
hey if Trump wants to have more than
just one show if he wants an entire
network for himself maybe everyone in
his family can have their own show so
like Don Jr can have a show and Eric can
have a show maybe Tiffany Trump can have
her own show we'll see how this all
works out I want to thank everyone for
tuning in after the break we're going to
David taking live calls and David
answering audience questions and stuff
that we had prepared from earlier in the
week this is the last footage that
you'll be able to see if David with an
appendix intact so I hope you enjoy the
rest of the show today thanks for tuning
in